I've been such a fan of your show you
guys have such creative strange sketches
that one I love because San is such it
you keep watching Santa such a perv like
a cool surfer yeah oh my favorite
that's Peter Giles by the way who should
just be celebrated he's terrific he's
terrific and one of my favorite parts is
at the oceans oh I'll just boil a little
yeah yeah at the end when mrs. Claus
comes in they you know reconnect and and
he's a guy I got to grab all my [ __ ]
it's like one like his one Santa hat and
like puts it on his yeah I'm told and
this is a big topic of conversation
today you went to the women's March in
DC on Saturday I did that is a I've
heard it was a it was tough to March
because so many people showed up that it
was kind of hard almost to move yeah
yeah so there was a linear path from you
know the the east side to the west side
and then up past the Capitol and you
know just a straight line and there were
so many people that showed up that we
were all just standing on all the side
streets and at a certain point that you
know we were there for like an hour just
standing like well the marks is just
showing up right and it's like we all
became Canadians for the day and we're
very like aggressively polite right
gentle with what did you do to pass the
time then with you're just standing
around I'm not kind of a squirrel until
I packed all these little things in my
pockets one of them being face paint and
I brought it out and painted some lady's
faces with some like swirls and gold
stuff you did you get the permission
first or just sort of just with my
makeup
you